les soldats russes ont beau avoir
disparu des rues de rerson les habitants
vivent toujours dans la peur dans ce
quartier résidentiel plusieurs
projectiles se sont abattus sur cette
maison ces
occupants sont traumatisés
ils ont tiré toute la nuit et puis j'ai
entendu une explosion très très forte le
matin et le plafond a commencé à tomber
sur moi j'écris à mon fils avec qui je
vis Oleg Oleg et tu vivants il a dit oui
oui et à ramper hors des décombres
après s'être retiré le 11 novembre les
Russes se sont installés de l'autre côté
de la ville face à la rivière depuis une
semaine il bombarderait personne chaque
jour
résultat à peine rétabli l'électricité a
de nouveau été coupée
l'occupant qui est resté ici longtemps
et sait où se trouve nos infrastructures
tirent dessus et essaie de les détruire
nous faisons de notre mieux pour les
protéger en barricadant nos
installations stratégiques avec des sacs
de sable
des frappes russes qui ont largement
endommagé le réseau électrique national
plus de 500 localités ukrainiennes sont
aujourd'hui privées d'électricité